well of course the uk is not the only  place facing extreme heat at the moment  in europe the heat wave is spreading  right across it with multiple wildfires  and record temperatures recorded in a  number of countries  in france temperatures are set to reach  about 39 degrees centigrade in some  areas in the southwest in a heatwave  that's predicted to last something like  eight or ten days seven areas have been  placed under an origin alert today by  the french government meanwhile spain  has already seen temperatures in the low  40s so far this week it's expected to  intensify in the southwest  that could hit about 47 degrees from  and across the border in neighboring  portugal conditions are expected to  gradually worsen between now and the  next few days maximum temperatures again  hitting around 47 degrees